I don't know what is it what is that
monthly free we bill around here what is
12,000 20,000 what it's up to like
twenty thousand dollars a month in we
know month just for you guy like him one
forty eight forty well your mouth hey
everybody welcome to another episode of
hot box and I'm Evan Britain I'm like
Dyson yes sir and we got the man Jason
Lee in the house I'm here how are you
I'm pretty cool brother I'm surprised to
see you smoking why [ __ ] because I
wasn't as in tune with how high you get
oh that's the highest form of thinking
listen I got out the car on the street
and I [ __ ] got high at the driveway
that's what we do here what you live it
yeah
you smoke a little weed welcome thank
you for welcome here tell us about your
blog how many [ __ ] um people watching
you I mean we get about 180 million
impressions a week across all what
hundred eighty million tell me about
that 100 million people is checking you
out yeah they go to all of our stuff
across all our platforms so we're active
on Instagram Facebook YouTube our
website have a podcast as well I've been
what is it I mean how come he has all
this [ __ ] and we don't you guys know I
got a whole situation this is like real
he started he started off just as a
hobby and I mean it's kind of grown into
a pretty - hobby but the way that we do
this [ __ ] yeah but y'all just had up
here y'all haven't really opening the
but earlier legends so and I mean yeah
you know everybody wants to come and
talk to Mike I know I was out here I've
definitely heard about you know scared
though no but but I'm scared no I don't
love in here but I'm not scared at all I
like I was telling my team on the way
over here it's so crazy because I grew
up in the era of Mike Tyson boxing and
it was done through the eighties [ __ ]
tonight I mean I was born in 77
are you serious got good skin I'm 41
77 yeah so good I thought you're my age
I'm not here baby huh you may be what 42
I'll be 42 in August yeah I grew up
pretty hair of watching you know you
kill everybody in the ring and now come
in here and you're just the kindest
sweetest I need to get to this toad
story at some point go ahead I want to
do it now I've never heard anybody
smoked a toad but how would it smoke in
a toad that break it down please I'm not
good so the Sonoran Desert toad
hibernates for ten months a year comes
out during the wet season and they
collect these toads and they milk them
they have these these glands on their
body that secretes this venom that
contains five m EO DMT 5 m EO DMT is
really the top of the pyramid oh you
tonight no I've never stole from you
I've never done anything bad about I've
never written a bad story about you I'm
a fan I'm surprised I'm here I'm y'all
are gonna figure out you made a mistake
at some point but I'm just thankful to
be here okay
absolutely it's multi-dimensional though
this life now you know maybe you met him
somewhere else in a dream you know I've
had that a lot I'm I figured out before
also yeah absolutely good vibes from you
J so my co-host Melissa is definitely
gonna want to [ __ ] you and she's
definitely gonna want to get high with
you so we we want to figure out sexing
highness this is [ __ ] it goes
together like [ __ ] water and bread
and Melissa thank you later water and
bread baby
so five Meo DMT powerful compound comes
from the Sonoran Desert toad they
collect this venom on a piece of glass
they dry it overnight
now you can scrape it off you put it
into a pipe you smoke it and you go and
you know have an experience of God
people are cured of addiction and
depression and anxiety it helps in
myriad ways and Mike had a really
powerful experience with it I have not
done that I've done ayahuasca and DMT
which is like a step below it's still a
psychedelic
entheogenic which means it's a compound
that creates an experience of God within
yourself so Mike had that experience but
is it like like an experience with God
like hallucinating type of thing or is
it lifts and that's what you're saying
that you say that because my friend is
just hell-bent on making me do mushrooms
I'm like I thought you were just [ __ ]
off the hook but mushrooms is not even
on the same level this that's right they
were here but the tow
[Music]
I feel like I died
it's my brother every time you go job
everything that I'm stripped from
everything that everybody think that I
am I don't know if I'm a [ __ ] I [ __ ]
I don't know what I'm afraid of it's
just all the feeling that I'm feeling
it's almost like God dying have to be
porous cuz I just was so life can be
glorious definitely
you know you realize after this
experience when you wake up I'm there's
no more fear of death and you know your
only purpose is to worship God really
yeah nothing everything that everything
that you do no anything that you love
everything you love right now you're
willing to kill and die for anything you
can't if that's your you forget about
don't exist no more nothing exists then
what's the purpose after that Hey
you're nothing wow that's the purpose is
but I don't want to get high to find out
I'm nothing like no no listen that's how
you're gonna feel me know when you
realize that I'm about to leave here 10
minutes or so from now like when the
time of your death you'll realize you
know me nothing matters no it's not
bigger than you it's really bigger than
you and I ego doesn't mean nothing it's
an illusion you feel more inspired in
your mission as an individual coming out
of those experiences because you are now
conducting yourself acting in a way that
is driven by I am a particle of spirit
the great thing that we're all a part of
and I have a mission here to do whatever
it is you know for me it's to help
people heal to spread positivity and to
shift people into a higher level of
consciousness I don't know what that is
for you you know for Mike it's about you
know changing the way people see the
world you know and and releasing a lot
of pain for people and it does change
the way you see people in the way know
me see itself only talk to people you
know you're not making these decisions
about what you're going to do with your
life there's a path there's a divine
path that is connected directly to the
source of everything that is guiding you
guiding you to be the best possible you
you can the best you but is that just
being super high like I've gone then you
don't get high it doesn't get you high
it doesn't you know no you don't get
high that's the interest aspects you
know what it but it puts you out no no
but we'll listen listen you listen me so
let me explain this yeah
you have a pie meal Glenn mm-hmm the
third eye okay
so there's a part of your brain that
releases DMT okay we created in our in
our brains and so what they believe is
you get two hits of DMT in your lifetime
this is one explanation or theory about
it so well you get one hit when you come
into being in your mother's womb and you
could get one hit on your deathbed and
they say that it's the portal of the
soul so this molecule is what takes our
spirit from the physical realm into the
spirit but what if you get in that
portal and gets stuck or you don't make
it through you know against these things
if there are thousands and thousands of
years old okay you know people have been
using these incident with someone's
taking it yeah I want to see that so
when you go in as Mike Tyson the Mike
Tyson because I have an image of who you
are yeah of course being watching you
over the years you cook you go in there
and you come out completely different oh
yeah I would say that yeah yeah you come
definitely more humble I believe and
what everybody thinks about listen one
experience I did about five time but in
one experience right
I got in a situation where I was I
didn't see no way and it's my body
wasn't it was just my feelings and I had
the feel of everybody knowing all my
secrets the whole world knew everything
I did that I would never want them to
know and I had the feeling than when he
knowing and that feeling oh whoa
but did it feel free for fear scary I'm
at first it was scary then it became
liberating liberating yeah why
definitely I mean I don't I don't get
high I mean I do want to get into
edibles last time I did ever thought I
had what I thought I was dying so I
don't do anything but you should check
the tote out dude that sounds scary as
hell my team will look at me [ __ ]
crazy Montoya I come into the team
meeting and I've had a whole new
reevaluation of life because if you know
your team will worship you and wanna be
where you at it's kind of scary I think
you'll because I'm already a lot sober
or a lot not high performers getting
eyes all about I need to learn new ways
of getting higher because smoking just
my lungs aren't made for it it's and
then you know I don't really know about
getting that edible game I ate a candy
bar I really thought I was dying
yeah that happened it could be scary now
yes that little um and that's when I'm
the kind of guy right I'm an extreme
kind of cat and I'm not the guy I can't
do this I can't like alright I could
take no it's a piece of cake I don't do
that gotta eat the flower the whole cake
else I'm not gonna eat it at all I can't
that someone lives my life you know I
get sometimes I eat I eat I get 70 80
pounds won't work out Etha why I don't
know why and then I have to go back and
you're starving living my life like that
again miserable not eating anything for
months then working out and stuff um I
do that that's just my life and I can't
stop doing it I don't know why I do that
wait so I always wanted this now that
I'm here now that I'm sitting in front
why are you employed not best friends I
don't understand you both are like the
best fighters ever live fearless I mean
global conversation
a tional starters mega brands but also
just seemingly very humble people
I mean privately you know Floyd's humble
privately thing then [ __ ] humble
privately I think so yeah I mean with me
he's humble I feel like I have a very
humbling effect on people oh really oh
[Music]
no I mean I don't know you I don't know
I just kind of thought you guys I
thought there would be like a clique of
like champions that just hang out
champions Club it's wrong no sometimes I
do want to click with him and then
sometimes I say [ __ ] with two different
species of [ __ ] yeah well yeah when
you're married right yeah I apologize to
your wife watching I didn't know I just
saw the ring after my comment I'd like
you to avoid my mouth is just so
reckless nice really nice of you but no
oh no oh no I don't hate Floyd yeah oh
yeah nice never saying anything negative
I just thought you guys to be friends
I'd like to talk [ __ ] I would love to
see you two together we need to figure
that out in faith time to make it right
down Jason said you guys do a thousand
negative Jason faced him right now yeah
right now it was talk it's not love he's
gonna do an interview right now say
what's up Cole know me Texas tell him I
said hi oh well I'm gonna tell them to
face something right now I don't know
where he is
so like sorry I'm gonna tell me that I'm
doing Mike champion Mike Tyson do you
care do you care to be reference to the
champ nice what Mike Tyson me know my
name no I know I'm just saying I'm Jim
I'm just saying in life nothing I'm
saving life because now with this whole
euphoric experience with the toad it's
[ __ ] toad that now I mean like do you
do you like the fact that we all still
look at you as like one of the listeners
my life um I don't um I don't like that
guy who Jim did you don't like being the
car the champ I don't like him
personally
no me
that guy Mike Tyson the champ the the
baddest [ __ ] on the planet I don't like
him you don't know why I had my reasons
do you have a problem with us liking him
sometimes yeah I mean cuz some of us
that was in a group home like me I was
in a group home watching - I grew up in
a group home - yeah you were like you
were the epitome of greatness you know
for somebody that I mean although I'm
mixed with a tie and I was a young black
man in an urban community and just to
watch you just be the best every time
you got in the ring was it was amazing
so like on the way over here I'm like he
clearly I don't know how I got here but
thank you oh no listen everything's
meant to happen for a reason
yeah none coincidental in life yeah
nothing it's just it's meant to be it's
meant to be you know even when your
first point your life is really an you
think you you think you know you you
navigate your life but you're not you
know it's just meant to be if you say
they said why didn't if I jumped in off
the track right now my life would be
different but you wasn't meant to jump
off the track it's just happen
no God ordains our life to be the way it
is yeah but being the champ also I think
resembles being the best and I think we
should all like should we all strive to
be the best at whatever we do because
that's what the champ represented yeah
we should be the best everybody should
be in the best of what they do and um my
perspective was the best word was
because I'm listen I didn't want become
a fighter because um I like this
technique he was awesome he was smart he
I liked the fighter because um I like
the way the reporters talked about great
fighters I've read about great fighters
they 1819 and I've read out the purposes
that people wrote about my [ __ ] this
guy's like this guy's almost like um
he's talking about Jesus and that's what
attracted me the fighting the way the
reporters wrote about the guides hmm
yeah I somebody asked me outside what
the purpose of life was I'm trying to
figure that out I mean I know what I do
is not my purpose it's my passion for
sure
I think your passion provides you the
platform to live out your purpose but I
mean I know ultimately I remember I'm
a group home kid and you know all the
experiences I have I just went to the
like I said I just I I wake up every day
and I just say I'm thankful that God has
allowed me to like make it through
because you know I've had a lot of
friends that have died I've had my just
just a lot of things have happened over
life where I'm like wow like there's no
way you can't acknowledge that there is
a God funny story so I'm all wiling out
we're in Atlanta I wasn't high but I was
hanging out with somebody who was high
and we got to talking and he was smoking
weed and he goes you and I said you know
I'm just thankful to God for all these
opportunities and he said which God and
I'd say well hold on we're not gonna do
that because I'm not gonna let you
question my god not in front of me y'all
could do that privately then a few days
later he lost his job he lost he got
kick I guess fired him shot - Nicky did
a great job and I thought like there you
go you know for me my purpose I think
has been grounded in the fact that I
know no matter how much fear I'm having
through a situation that there's faith
i'ma make it through because I believe
in God so to look at somebody like that
just just just dismiss God and just this
or whatever and then the next few days
like lose the opportunity guy gave them
was crazy
listen um I think you think that but I
think certain ways - I think God who
loved it maybe the universe or whatever
our thoughts and stuff so inconceivable
to him you know well we can't even
imagine talking to go we can't even
imagine God we can't even put draw a
picture of God
you know it's inconceivable to us no
matter how smart we believe we are how
smart we actually are cards still
inconceivable to us and still we believe
in them you know yeah so um in my
perspective you know me you're a
religious man I'll say up spiritual more
than that I don't go to church every
Sunday but only thing we know about
religion is because people told us about
it and people told our mothers about it
and our fathers about it and then Jesus
and Christ happened 10,000 years ago
whatever and that happened but only
thing we know fixing from worried about
for what people told us but we asked
y'all know the truth how we got here
what is up but I mean we don't believe
we came from monkeys
I mean I don't believe they were monkeys
walking on the beach and then they I
don't know how do you know I don't
believe that that's your beliefs maybe
for a lot of people who believe
everybody believed it on darling darling
believe that that's the name Doran
Barbara Barr went on he was pretty smart
allegedly right yeah no absolutely
absolutely
allegedly here and there's in trouble
yeah but you know we don't run a lot of
holes that's why we have those stuff
cause we don't know we all really don't
know I can't tell you anything I can't
we really don't know you only know what
people tell us what we really believe so
what is the purpose of life doing that's
what somebody asked me out there I don't
know nobody is but to be the best you
could possibly be yeah I agree with that
that's what LL Cool J told me after it
be the best you could possibly be yeah
be at your maximum potential and then
share it with the world
yeah okay then maybe I'm on track I do
believe I do believe I'm becoming the
best at what I am I mean I feel like it
still requires a lot of work 180 million
impressions is great but I'm 180 billion
impressions you know and I don't even
think there's ever enough I mean I don't
look at the money part because the money
comes with the success I think the money
comes with a hard work and being
dedicated to that hard work because I've
seen a lot of money coming and I've
looked at my account money we reinvested
it in the brand we weren't out buying
Bentleys and [ __ ] planes and all that
we are literally investing in people
infrastructure building and and building
our community because I feel like you
know I look at like Oprah
you know people feel what they feel
about Oprah personally you know she
cancelled after what she did to Mike
Tyson I mean I Mike Jackson I don't know
she was on my show for a little bit but
you know she came from nothing and she
built her audience focusing on being who
she was and out of that came the riches
and everything else so I feel like today
a lot of the younger people I run into
especially people that just moved to LA
I won't even waste like 30 minutes with
somebody telling me their whole vision
for their stay in LA I'm like if you're
not coming here and getting grounded and
exploring where you play a part in all
this and how to bring everything here
into your world first is you being in
everybody else's world you gonna be on
the next flight home anyway so I can't
even invest again you know you're
selling your ass and one of these
corners or something for it
well back pages now they go online
but yeah you will I think you're right
on I mean doing this show hanging out
with Mike getting to know Mike meeting
guys like LL Cool J Snoop Tony Robbins
like these [ __ ] guys you look like
Tony Robbins thank you alright
successful
square jaw awesome person awesome guy
but it's really the common thread to me
is exactly what you're saying is these
guys have just they know exactly who
they are and they [ __ ] cultivated the
hell out of that through their own
discipline their own you know particular
practices whatever worked for them and
they have created this super [ __ ]
potent message that they just blast out
into the world their meteoric type
energies you know and I think you have a
lot of that too man and what you're
doing and I think that's really you know
why you are successful you know and why
people gravitate to what you're saying
is because you are speaking truth into
the world you know you [ __ ] to use
Mutulu you could be [ __ ] lie right
now what's the difference between the
two and let you think we looking for you
feel it from your yeah spiritual eyes
you know when you're talking to somebody
who's being transmitted listen I'm I'm
41 black gay openly gay not closeted gay
like a lot of the people in Hollywood
I'm very transparent what I think I say
what I feel I say I feel like the
honesty saves everybody time and I don't
care about being everybody's friend what
I care about is figuring out how do we
create an ecosystem where young black
boys or girls or people of color or
people period around the world who are
looking at us feel like they too could
become great you know like me sitting
here you know as much as I'm in the
conversation like you know I know you
don't want us to gravitate to that image
of who you are but you are one of the
greatest athletes to ever live so and I
know how important you were to all of us
young black kids sitting around watching
you you know when
time after time especially in the time
where we believed because life served us
this perspective that we could not win
so I think that you know I don't I know
I was great about I think what we're
talking about is that who you are to all
of us as a boxer doesn't define who you
are as a human being on this earth and
I've learned a lot just being here from
talking to the people Ryan you have a
lot of good energy and the whole being
kind is I think hopefully you now living
out your purpose which would teach me
the longevity of being successful at my
craft and then getting to my purpose and
having the same success oh no that's
interesting did you say that thank you
but um try to say one thing
what what do you want to say you can say
anything Mike without that that guy that
you don't like this guy is impossible
special you know I would never want to
you know I think sometime would you do
it again my kind
yeah I will do this [ __ ] I there's so
many things that you know things happen
the thing that did the people and even
though you may say so you could never
take back yeah you know you can forgive
yourself but you know from a moral
perspective from your barometer that
that was wrong yeah but see you know and
you know it's how you I mean to cut you
off but how you is how you do your own
Clarence pretty much you know it's how
you handle your own clearancing that's
how I handle my inventory yeah you can
say this Mike dude but that's how I head
into my inventory yeah you know yeah I
mean for me the mmm the I've done a lot
of bad things I've done a lot of good
things I've done a couple great things I
tried not to live with regret only
because I know there's a lesson in
everything I tell the story of me and my
mother and when she put me in foster
care I came out with tons of animosity I
was mean to her intentionally I mean she
could say good morning I love you and I
would and I'm just being honest here I
would say [ __ ] I ain't trying to hear
that cuz I was so angry it wasn't until
she was dying
well a little bit before she was dying
we had you know reconciled and all that
and I was still it was so hard to tell
her I loved her even though I knew she
was you know really ill or whatever
so I would send her flowers with a card
that would say these are overdue I would
send her tokens of my affection without
me having to sit there and watch her
receive it right but right before she
died I said to her she said I did the
best that I can and I acknowledge that
oh she's telling me that she did the
best she could she was limited so I
learned in that moment forgiveness how
it was for me not necessarily just for
her I learned how to appreciate people's
limitations although they may not be
able to live up to mine I you know will
continue to just allow the universe to
bring together whatever it brings
together but do the best I can
in at all and I just remember like all
the bad things led me through lessons
that taught me to be greater so I try
not to regret it all because then it'll
be I'll feel like my whole life was a
waste like everything I've been through
that I don't want to acknowledge like it
just doesn't matter therefore did I
matter during that time so I just try to
accept it all getting bad yeah
oh no that's the dance I think when do
we find out what's right or wrong
do we ever there's no right it's just in
your feelings yeah the under the toad
you really there's no right or wrong but
just but you're battling with demons I'm
wrong guys oh my god I should have done
oh my god he's noan isn't why what are
you tripping out right no it's gonna
punish nuns gonna happy but my mind my
perception that it's gonna happen I
should be punished this is bad Oh cuz
when you're under total feeling you have
a head
the first soda the first cigarette the
first kiss the first sex perfectly all
those mostly is just some it's [ __ ] I
speed it clean and yes anything first
and you yes it is overwhelming
overwhelms you just don't know what to
say what to doing you yes well existing
if it doesn't matter why do good you
know I think everyone wants to people
know why in listen everybody this is the
one song because at the end when it's
all over we really believe in the
atheist that we're gonna have to pay for
our sins in some way we all believe that
we're gonna pay for something and we're
gonna meet God and I don't care if
you're a thief or nothing you know I
mean why would you say this is horn life
journey I want
be good I want to be good because it's a
payoff from a good or bad we gotta meet
somebody somebody yeah you know you know
the first two firsts here the first
Neanderthal you know it's an ugly
monster probably had ingrown nails teeth
hanging things look like amongst poly
could even walk they prayed to something
and for the bug a rock or something a
flower at the consciousness their brain
was as big as a peanut but into the
worship something yeah and I think if
there were no people and nobody to love
and or hurt inflict pain upon it
probably wouldn't be a natural instinct
to destroy the nature around you yeah it
would be more of an instinct to utilize
it and learn how to live with it and
even help it prosper mm-hmm wouldn't it
I think so but I also think people I
mean you're the first human there's no
other humans in this hypothetical
situation and you are you wake up you
know in the [ __ ] jungle in a forest
somewhere mm-hmm and you know nothing
other than you are of this landscape but
still what would be your instinct let's
do I'm gonna tell you what this is you
know nothing history proved what I
instinct was I hadn't instincts were to
build things I'm constantly and create
the build thing that destroyed the earth
to pollute the air islet am innate the
waters I even say like I was just saying
yesterday I need to go on vacation
somewhere like Turks and Caicos or
Maldives something really sterile and
calm and I know me I will get there I
want to be on my Instagram I want to be
on my email and like what you're saying
like in terms of like I think the world
does have a way of just sucking us into
cycles where we're continuously on this
cycle of having to do something when
sometimes doing absolutely nothing but
enjoy nature or just you know the raw
earth is what we should be
I believe this right if all the ants in
the world died the world will die if all
the elephants in the world died the
world would die well the trees died in
the world the world would died if all
the humans died the world was full of
Instagram Goes Down the world will die
you know yeah that happened but listen
but if all of us died
the world was flourished yeah and the
world doesn't need us so what are we
here for to pollute the world to destroy
get all the oil that we get we polluted
ocean and all the time the gasket fuels
and fumes and stuff we put in the air
and [ __ ] cut off what's that thing I
lay out off the solar layer yeah yeah oh
so ligament yeah I think people just
don't have a sense of ownership when it
comes to the climate or when it comes to
the world because I don't even think are
like in just in terms of communities we
feel obligated to one another as much
anymore I feel like I don't know
everybody's just I'm so much isolation
yeah for sure
I don't know for me Mike when you give
that argument because I know that I know
of that and you've said it before and I
know it's true my thing is then okay
yeah we do all that we're clearly great
at doing that as [ __ ] this place up
and sucking it dry and you know
eventually if we don't change our ways
and how we treat the planet and the
environment and animals and nature if we
don't change how we conduct ourselves
with that you know we are gonna [ __ ]
pay for that there's no doubt about that
but so the other side of that coin is
why are we here then it's to help this
thing [ __ ] prosper and flourish and
be as healthy and beautiful and abundant
how do we do that Mike how do we do that
by I'm cracking the ground open and
digging deep we don't do it by that huh
you know we do it by utilizing these
great chimneys any great factory with
the things our olds only do you think
how do we do without that when you think
about electing people who actually
believe that it's important to do that
because I don't believe absent me I
you don't believe in climate change in
the ozone layer and I mean don't believe
in he don't believe in global warming
yeah he is the leader of the free world
you know we don't you know when they
send these [ __ ] you know they send these
things to what would ascend to Mars and
Jupiter they trying to get the infernal
foot please that's not we can never live
on Mars and Jupiter but no why they send
these asked easy
um astronaut machine astronauts because
they wanted to get the minerals out of
the planet yeah you know I was me in
French you were talking today and I was
extinct do you know Jupiter that it
rains diamonds mmm and Jupiter ring mom
if we land on Jupiter right now we
probably fall through the diamond
through the diamond through the actual
diamonds yeah look it up you really know
so just getting high make you more
intellectual because I feel like you
read and study and research more when
you're [ __ ] yeah I think you do
that's why they call it high cuz you get
a highest level it changes your
perspective you know you're conscious
Haislip you can't think any higher how
you get that the more I'm intuitive you
become but after you get high for a
while does it make do you at least
balance it out cuz I feel like vice
Awesomenauts most too much I shouldn't
smoke too much really chunks of diamonds
may be floating in hydrogen and helium
fluid deep in the atmospheres of Saturn
and Jupiter that's crazy
yeah what's more it even lower depths
the extreme pressure and temperature can
melt the precious gem yeah but you can't
make it rain it has a carpet you can't
on we can't live on the planet you can't
breathe and if you didn't follow the
plan you probably sink in the diamond
that I kill you right yeah keeping the
diamonds suffocate you if they put all
those diamonds on this planet be it
suffocated all of us they're animals the
water and but we all die too many from
Diamond a [ __ ] man no way it a killer
floor can't cash for diamonds be too
many a times the Killa her it'll kill
the world the whole world would die for
you putting this is too depressing now
no way
def is glorious really someone I went to
church one day and the guy said
everybody wants to go to heaven but
nobody wants to die and that [ __ ] me no
but listen they don't they don't want to
die because they don't know if they're
that's the only reason right once you
have to believe for worth there you know
and then toad will help you see it well
perhaps it did myself I can say was unto
you he had me to terrifying she's after
this world is a base fear based worth
when you gonna feel this way you know
she's not allowed that to happen you
need to shop with kids for that I wasn't
called a kid I like that yeah listen you
31 what do you want one
listen enough 52 in our 5333 is young no
but you're not but you're not 53 not yet
where do you get the 53 you in real life
41 was young true 31 John you have 30
one's really cool hey one's really cool
31 is cool so do you guys smoke like I
know weed there's BAM are we which is
like bad we right is that bad more do
they still have that we have the best in
the world
so this person run this is top line any
better cream is across so do you get
high off your own supply yeah yes but um
in moderation I don't know what is it
what is that monthly free weed bill
around here what is twelve thousand
twenty thousand forty some to late
twenty thousand dollars a month in we
know month
yeah just for you guy like in one it's
more than that with the weed yeah 48:40
for your mouth lousy yeah you know
what's very interesting is this place is
super high functioning yeah this place
is beautiful right this place is let me
tell you something I go to a lot of
[ __ ] places this [ __ ] I was fit for
what we do here is known as we smoke a
lot of weed all right Jason you were
telling a story earlier before we came
in here I think you got a share with
Mike blindfold
building in El Segundo so I was on my
way out here I was in the car and I was
looking I was like damn are we going on
the [ __ ] Airport where we going but
anyway our last time I came out here
last Alonso the actor he hit he called
me up I was out drinking with Melyssa
Ford my co-host and he said I want you
guys in takara I want you guys go with
me to a party I said okay
go to a party we're drinking we're
already out so we get in the car as
we're going to the party he's starting
to reveal to us that it's a different
type of party and that we're gonna be
required to wear blindfolds we hid their
[ __ ] listen I've been some of these
parties [ __ ] so we were we roll up to a
open parking lot with a van and a white
man with a tie on and a briefcase and
like five white people staying in the
parking lot and they get out he opens
his briefcase and then he proceeds to
blindfold all of us and then were taken
to this other building by way of I think
a car I can't remember how we get there
by way across the street no we had to
walk we had to walk really far but it
ended up just walking around the corner
because they didn't want us to know
where we were we had to stand in line
any long story short when you go inside
the party was all SNM you had to do
everything they told you to do and every
time you did it
those whose party this guy's Alonso
knows this group is fun to [ __ ] lasses
last so what laughing let's check this
[ __ ] oh right yeah yeah Alonso al dia
very right there
okay so let's so every time the people
at the party at the national party tell
you what to do if you don't do it you
have to take off a piece of your clothes
so by the end of the day by the end of
the night Lazarus in his boxers he had
nothing on but boxers and he was in bed
with two women who I think had gagged
him and we were all I guess on our knees
praying I don't know what was what it's
the weirdest [ __ ] ever oh yo we'll have
a [ __ ] El Segundo there's no phones
you can't bring phones in it's very
private there's performances there's
didn't make it dinner party [ __ ] no
something lives on blast
laughing I'm glad this is not putting
less on glass we've talked that laughter
the fact Phatak probably huh he wasn't
black sex I wanna come a Hollywood show
he's the big book I can handle it all he
does a lot of love movie so yeah there's
a lot of that you know definitely made
me see avatar a lot differently now you
know you get a star an avatar but yeah
it was a quite an experience no they get
folk caught up you listen you get caught
up out here man it was fun time it's
it's an actual production you guys
should call it a little sighting it's
like a it's like a nerd it's dark
amusement park you know your thrill
chills and spills it really is true
Hollywood it Hollywood's like this um no
we're group of people right and we're
different from these people okay and our
job isn't to make sure we stay together
and not let these people into our [ __ ]
you know that mean mm-hmm and don't get
caught up with these people cuz you're
gonna get left out with these people not
being on [ __ ] no more and that's how it
goes
I always wanted this I always wonder
this is once you [ __ ] nothing you
can't [ __ ] with hey we can't be around
you know hey we can't be seen with you
know hey you can't [ __ ] with you Hey
winner Harvey we're not home hey hey
we're doing something right now there's
no more you're the man you always my
favorite kids are hugging me I love your
kids I'm Uncle Mike in this and that
that's no more happy than you with them
now but sometimes these guys work they
way back up in there hardly stayed they
see maybe 10 20 years they stick to the
grindstone they work hard they [ __ ]
crying and grinding don't kiss ass and
then one day they had that lead party
and this [ __ ] comes back in your back
huh you know this is after making two or
three billion dollars I'm back
[ __ ]
there's a strong don't die no they come
back they do never you know I always
tell people to like do you on your own
terms
nobody me I didn't you know I will say
going back to Floyd one thing he did
teach me just like own your own [ __ ] and
don't let nobody control you you
and it's hard when you're building by
yourself at first you know until you get
people's attention and then it gets
easier but it's still hard but it's
missing right people don't always own us
we're never gonna think so never really
you believe so why do you feel you own
now and only if you had money you
wouldn't be owned no I don't believe if
that's why I said earlier I don't
believe the money isn't the driver it's
not the drivers building the audience
and building the community that to me is
the driver you think you actually are
thinking right now
do you consciousness thank you writing
of course who formed your thought why
for my thought how did the form
I mean you as an assess I know how did
you do a form my thought is formed based
on an assessment of everything and I'm
involved with her that I'm experiencing
at that particular moment yeah I'm a
definitely fires off against everything
that makes me who I am I think so know
where to start come from no I would
think that my thought came from what I
saw information yeah but sometimes which
I know that this is a cool conquer they
told me it's a cool car but you ain't
never seen a beautiful woman and said
and found out oh that's a man sometimes
what you see what everything you can
look at somebody and you can say that's
a beautiful woman and then find out it's
a man at what you thought you saw ain't
until you got more information now you
know it's a different situation no
there's not information listen it's
still a man but this is what I want you
know I want this I want what I see I
don't see the man but when you get more
information than you can assess whether
you actually want that or not yes but at
this moment information is [ __ ]
incidental I want that and nothing's
gonna stop me from getting that and then
when I get it I get it and when I find
it's not what I want I dispose of it
okay because that's the information how
I get information hmm unless they have a
really big Adam's apple then it just the
informations out I don't know about that
but nobody's useless
everybody's useful I agree to that
there's no such thing as useless people
everybody has value yes I agree to that
it's so crazy in the city that I don't
think that's the majority opinion though
I think people do feel like people are
it easily
you know they live here yeah ethical do
an instant gratification you know after
the new world we can't get it in the 80s
and effeminate if you want instant
gratification you worked hard for you
took it you know they didn't working and
when that in the old day that that
happened overnight
yeah takes years to build an empire yeah
well it's interesting to hear you say
that Mike because your way of thinking
about it of bringing all of this energy
and just going all out is so unique and
sort of part of this you know how people
get to be Mike Tyson or what's so
inspiring about you know Mike LL Cool J
you know these superstars that show
people how to be human and how to access
all aspects of themselves you know and
to be a full embodiment of who they are
you know because I think so many people
don't know who they are
thanks dude Matt thank you thank you
Frenchy shout out Frenchy Fred I think
the dangerous part
I think the dangerous part of what you
just said though for me and I agree with
everything you said but there's there's
another side to it yeah you know I
remember when Kanye West first came out
and said I'm a king I'm a god I'm this
people destroyed him and I yes and I
thought he is and I thought he is I am
you are we are we already should embody
the belief that they are great yeah I
don't care about your circumstance who
don't love you but why do we wait until
the world says you're great to say we're
great you know I I had a problem with
that because there were different times
out walking rooms and I agree and I
would dim my light because I didn't want
to try to look like I'm out shining
people when naturally some people do
homes I'm right at another to rub people
listen them people are funny they know
Kanye is great too but the way you
conduct some stuff they hate to believe
it but they can't help it they know he's
great right
why would listen the corny [ __ ] Kanye's
say is basically affirmations where
people say for success and it sounds
insane because that's what [ __ ]
do but he sounds insane and that science
sounds of a leader no doubt he got some
mental [ __ ] issues most leaders do
the delusional issue I'm a god
yeah that's what all of us don't have
because we're still stuck with no we
still have to pay our respects to the
garden here that we don't see it's
inconceivable that God could put
somebody on the earth that could be you
know God like God liar
yeah well will you believe he did the
Jesus you believe you did apart from
Mohammed you believe he did what um and
that Gandhi was said the brother while
those stories are spun as these are
Buddha on television yeah you know there
others but how about the people that
don't discover them and don't say
they're from God and they can be for how
do we know they're not actually
descendants of God and everybody that
was a descendant from God we all hate it
we're all we all wanted to kill them we
all wanted to do something too bad to
them that's part of the lie all right so
that's what we want to do - Kanye yeah
and I think more people should grow up
believing that their kings their parents
if you don't have parents their
communities should make them feel like
they're Kings I don't think you should
be persecuted for wanting to be God like
it doesn't mean that you're proclaiming
to be God I did feel like the sense of
shame people and this was before the
whole make America great [ __ ] you
know him in Trump or whatever but it's
funny you know I
my criticism Akane - I did go to the the
Sunday service thing that he has tell me
about that [ __ ] so that went to like
probably the second one and it was you
know Earth Wind & Fire David Letterman
Kardashian's a small group of people but
then I broke us and and I've actually
sat with Kanye and I've sat in his house
and I've been in his house I've sat with
them and he a we had a great
conversation but then I broke a story
about Chloe and Tristan Thompson but I
gave Chloe the heads up and we're cool
me and Chloe are cool about it but then
Connie I was disinvited from a Sunday
service and I thought was so crazy I'm
probably one of the people in the
culture who drive the culture through
our our company that actually supports
you yeah and and it's just funny that
like we don't have to be there to know
what you're doing because you're there
and phones are there and people now
social media you can't [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] without putting it on Instagram you
know but I just find it interesting how
like I don't know man this city
something else I don't I don't I try to
work in it but not be of it like and I
just that's not the right way to be
about it man no way listen you too
emotional about it being emotional
even a listen if you're not smart enough
to be my friend [ __ ] you yeah pretty
much
come on man chill out man get some
[ __ ] balls yeah but no I've told many
people [ __ ] them you know tell Kanye
[ __ ] you [ __ ] okay [ __ ] you Kanye [ __ ]
[ __ ] remember that's just what it is
man you could listen if you my friend
you my [ __ ] friend [ __ ] you I could [ __ ]
you too my friend if you my friend [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
yeah like this is what I'm talking oh
brother this is what I'm talking about
you know you inspire people to [ __ ]
speak from the center of their soul how
do you talk to your friend that hurt in
this feeling or not well that's how you
should be friend of you supposed to love
him he's gonna get in trouble if you
don't check him I think he's gonna get
killed he's gonna get in jail he's gonna
get he you know you gonna be the one
spending time when it when he's [ __ ]
up and any kind of would mess up there
Kanye was never my friend let me be
clear I I brought cardi B over to the
house they really want to nobody say you
hang out with their know what I'm saying
was I brought cardi B to the house they
really wanted to be friends with cardi B
sure I'm just a byproduct of that
because I brought cardi B you notice
saying so it wasn't even no real like
synergy or energy type of [ __ ] it was um
I was some other so what's the con -
Ian's like man talk to me about a lot of
people talk [ __ ] about like I don't know
if I like about what I like them what I
like them I always talk positive about
what they want things on their terms
jealous - it's alright I'm not [ __ ]
I'm not [ __ ] on nobody sign your
saying this is the life this is life on
life turn you [ __ ] I hate on
the Kardashians are jealous because
anybody that could take an opportunity
like we're not opportunity anybody who
could take a lemon like that and turn it
into a franchisable lemonade store god
bless them I don't know nobody [ __ ]
with those it's a [ __ ] look at me
they don't even want me to [ __ ] what do
you look at that [ __ ] for you need to go
to service one is a [ __ ] billionaire
she started member she didn't handle
lips when she was a little kid now she's
a bay now you don't none of them look
the same
god bless him now god bless from I
respect him anybody that hustle anybody
jealous of them [ __ ] right even a
beard like bad baby be known for the
beauty and a sexuality
[ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] my husband
right now oh did you know about this
honey I know all my life about yeah okay
yeah Jason oh no my groom was the first
time you tell the story about coming
across the um [ __ ] mm I was at school
one day and somebody said um oh hi your
name is Mike Tyson you like the card the
guy from the Cardinals or something I
said what and then my brother that
brought the card home he's the collector
and he brought in I thought it was Mike
Tyson Oh forgot that but then I found
the Jewish Mike Tyson of the bunch Mike
Tyson's and everything because there's
an actor Jason Lee the guy from the yeah
there's a lot of the [ __ ]
if you see someone Jason the crow yeah
so my Instagram is the only Jason Lee
and it pisses their fans off well then
we need to get some other Jason Lee all
right so put in some Mike Tyson shot and
know what's going on we can got my [ __ ]
was what did I do wrong Yeah right
what did i do right but I know what they
might do right
[Music]
hey honey I'm in the podcast yeah I love
you yes yes Mike Tyson looking super
human downstage oh wait excuse me
that's the things you didn't know about
the former boxer all right what is it
that we didn't help up my black cat
Michel Gerard Tyson Georgia middle name
yeah you know
Jed's full name is Gerard yeah I'll
write you oh uh yeah
so what am i doing man what are you
doing
you look superhuman these days dude
you're doing a lot right these days my
tanks on dude
this place is money I walked up in here
man y'all got infrastructure y'all got
vision boy y'all a Plan C I ran I did I
was mad that first of all Adam here who
captures my my feet he had two friends I
went to your festival I didn't even know
about
oh we don't I'm ready to get on home
good what now I'm not gonna talk for you
but we can't we have some interesting I
want to go yeah October brother so does
everybody's gonna be smoking out there
we have a liquor license as well you
wanted to put a your necklace you could
sure you can do whatever you write so
I'm focused on losing weight so I still
want to get high smoke but don't drink
no stay away from the drink and listen
right I don't drink anymore suck the
water down and yes um you're out of
water in that treadmill though it's
gonna chill keep moving always walking
moving I know you can start off with
like 30 minutes and then we'll be
working wait maybe 15 30 as I've thought
over 15 minutes I did 15 minutes then
from 15 to 30 through 30 I went to 45
and 45 now I'm an hour
really yeah that did I want to have
today but that's a start
walking is a great thing to do I was 320
no I'll tell you though 6:36
I play you know when I was in the NFL I
left at 3:30 now I'm about 2:45 mmm when
I'm overweight I can't even
it hurts - [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
and you can't [ __ ] it's [ __ ] yeah no
value [ __ ] what's the famous Mike Tyson
saying you can't [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Pryor is it really surprising Mike put
it out there again have you do you know
about intermittent fasting I've heard
about it I mean is that just where I
mean we didn't have any money we
intermittent fasting all the time we
just didn't eat that what that means
like where you just don't eat you don't
eat for 16 hours a day so like from like
8:00 a.m. 8:00 p.m. seen hours say 8:00
p.m. till noon the next day okay so you
get 16 hours of fasting does that
intermittent fasting though okay so you
do that you eat in an eight-hour window
okay and that help that help everybody
knows I'm so confused now there's Kido
now there's juice [ __ ] it die well he
just eat real food you know like
everything that comes from the ground
yes yeah and from the trees shits boring
life is [ __ ] boring I said my sister
died of obesity whole family gets
begging [ __ ] I mean real big [ __ ]
comes down south big you know we can't
[ __ ] some five you can't [ __ ]
function walk a lot you know your heart
legs [ __ ] rubbing together and
[ __ ] burning and [ __ ] it's just what
it is you know that's who we are when
they say hide it with money we could
hide it with diet and [ __ ] but when it
comes to the [ __ ] real deal and you
didn't pass then you can't really
function you love your fat [ __ ] that's
what it is you know you can't stop
eating it's who you are you do you're
vegan but you know you're to get federal
vegan food we get fat and [ __ ] you know
people that I mean vegan food got some
fattening [ __ ] you can't function here
move your workout it's getting the
weight when they say go ahead Mike show
and just start talking you guys are
gonna figure out a whole conversation
just with no format
we did yes we do brother we just have a
come and nobody can actually plan you
like you got to come in here and be you
yeah yeah exactly
we're looking to find out who the [ __ ]
you are that see work with you got any
co-stars oh yeah yeah Todd your show so
we have a show called Hollywood unlocked
uncensored we started from when I
started after I did love in hip hop
because I felt like they edited me one
way and I needed a platform to kind of
control how we did what we did or
whatever so we started about three years
ago we've had some really good guests on
but yeah me Melyssa Ford and DJ damage
she's alive she was still around she was
messed up she was in a bad car accident
but she's great she's in London right
now yeah she's great
she bounced back he's great yes he is or
she is whoever's listening
some people think yeah God's a woman
okay well whoever you got is my god I
don't know I want to talk about what my
god oh god confusing he's owned it and
he confuses everything yeah in
everything everywhere you guys seem so
at peace this is a level of calmness
that you know my doctor just gave me
some medicine to sleep you know cuz now
I'm in this deep sleep maybe it's the
Frog medicine I don't know it's
something I feel really peaceful yeah I
feel more peaceful in here everything is
calm it's part of life growing up like
you say you're young
yeah I'm pretty nice to be a favish no I
know nobody's no I'm not no forget to
forget inside the ran from a human being
perspective he thought I didn't think
about people feeling [ __ ] that's what I
can see them know I'm hurting my wife
feelings about looking the wrong way you
know I was sitting yesterday I only said
next - how you doing and my wife [ __ ]
never said don't know why I was just
common thing to do and I said then why I
shouldn't I said that you know and I
inspired this is just um I said nothing
I remember ten years ago a few I was
been a [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'll do what the
[ __ ] I want to do I'm sorry
you know things with change you know my
fuse [ __ ] changes
I don't do the [ __ ] I used to do that's
crazy and that's what happens when you
get older when you're 51 52 you're not
gonna be the way you are in there that's
what I was gonna say so it's age or
maturity just growing yeah I didn't
think I was in when I was when I was in
my thirties I didn't think I was gonna
make it
yeah I didn't either I think I was I
have a question and I've always wanted
others don't like that in my 20s yeah
yeah it's a reckless guy drugs and women
Rex that's what my problems are but Don
King is his hair naturally like I would
always wanted this no he did that did he
do that Amy because I remember when the
troll dolls came on even natural now if
they made this t1 look like a crown
listen when those troll dolls came out I
was like I would have copy written that
hairstyle back in the day but yeah I
never trusted that here you bad brother
well what else wrecking [ __ ] is it the
14th season of while and now I did my
fourth season with them when they can
help me about that Nick it was Nick
about so Nick actually came on my
podcast and I just had left loving
hip-hop and wasn't on TV so I was like
you know a [ __ ] needs a job what's up
and he actually booked me on the show I
had never been a comedian tell me about
those show you look I'm gonna keep it
real I think I'm a one-man show you ever
watch luck you want to be on their
dignity he wants to come up my shadow
young [ __ ] [ __ ] if I look fun like a
mother for half those people even have
[ __ ]
that's okay it's just the fun of the
situation I'll give them I put my [ __ ]
out in their head that x2 just being
around that [ __ ] is just well if they if
they heard baby talking [ __ ] I know it's
[ __ ] around good [ __ ] right
yeah would you ever do it would you do
beyond now how and they seem old family
go up and [ __ ] flee I don't know
yeah but this might I have a show we're
gonna do one from rola with the punch or
punches he's in the - we got Mike Epps
we got how to doing everything over your
whole drink that we are a type of enzyme
acts links ya doings know God has been
really grateful I've been really great
for the garden he blessed us you know
you're doing good stuff you know I could
easily been on the other side of town
you know a man is very grateful that's
what I always have to grab to do I'm
trying to say so what do you think about
my boy Anthony Joshua you think he's
what do you think about that fight did
you care mistake got hurt and [ __ ]
happens
you know yeah I think all of us he come
back in one day and know they're back
though okay this might have to be right
he ain't gonna back of his mind [ __ ]
up you know his mind gonna be ride
together dedicated his life to doing
this stay away from Drake huh
you got stay away from Drake I don't
know who guys day we got stay away from
himself you know when we go training we
go away them and the mountains with
staying away from myself and I know it
is that are you trying yeah really and
the mountains away from everybody just
animals in the woods and stuff and your
faith in your demons alone what his
spirits are well I mean I
he's a great guy I listen his spirits up
appear well to you but in his mind
what's going on
[ __ ] you know that's what makes them
this the stage this life is really what
makes em yeah you know because we
already have money now
now it's all about know who are you now
you're doing with adversity who are you
what are you gonna do now you gotta lay
down now and you're here you got on the
more you lay down and keep it up do you
believe it in you got any [ __ ] pride
[ __ ] what do you believe in you believe
in your ancestors leaving your mother
your father your kids what do you
believe in what are you gotta fight for
damn I don't believe in [ __ ] maybe I got
money maybe I don't believe in on this
[ __ ] I bear fair that was and that's
cool to leave no you are hmm
damn well it's like I mean just that
fight is such a good illustration of
what you talk about Mike like you know
you might be a nobody you get a title
fight shot against the champ knock him
out you know the whole story change the
whole life change whole life changes you
have a job for the rest of your life
yeah somewhere they have a job for you
yeah just talking about your glory date
that one moment for Buster Douglas life
he has a job tell us about you upsetting
Mike Tyson what was it like being Mike
Tyson he was invincible how did you beat
him you're nothing how did that work out
they have that for the rest of their
life mm-hmm that's crazy
you were at the fight yeah how was the
energy in oh if I thought he was gonna
kill me these man we were planning the
after-party uh I flew in the party Wow
do they know me there's a way Oh Dave
she's about to be chanting I'm chilly
I'm [ __ ] the maid this [ __ ] was like
this big I'm not everybody knocking
about the nightmare by just probably
with this [ __ ] all right so as we know
that didn't happen right and now you
have to deal with that with yourself
was that hard cuz yeah yeah yeah you
arrogant [ __ ] [ __ ] do you think you
are
do you really think you karma [ __ ]
your [ __ ] uneducated [ __ ] your turns
out a fighting you and pre
Shadid piece of [ __ ] this how you
treated you don't work out you don't
train you got a deal with that yeah yeah
yeah I will say that I told Anthony I
don't think I can go to an it's
different when you watch your friends
play basketball you know running around
the court when you see two people that
one that you know fighting in a ring for
their title like watching Floyd was
stressful but I always went in like I
would watch you like we're gonna win how
did that with Anthony second row
ringside and it was like the whole life
of the room just was sucked out and was
really but he's not dead he's okay so he
don't want nobody feeling sorry for me
so he's like I'm good you know I mean I
got to get this together I got a I got
to go back to London I need to get in I
need to be focused I think was a wake-up
call for sure so he deserved good thing
he does he's a good person a good thing
and boxing is exciting with him yeah
Wilder fury like that whole group of
guys those young guys coming up I think
it's awesome I felt like when you left
and even like when Floyd left it kind of
felt like boxing was kind of dead it was
I feel like you not really slipped away
where the green I bought the [ __ ]
scary bad guy guy man bully man God and
he brought the [ __ ] player any much
I'm smarter than you
that's why you can't beat me because I'm
just you're inferior I'm superior
imagine I'm superior you shouldn't even
be breathing the same air but what's so
crazy about you I look they employed
would always play it to is like this
guy's lucky to be fighting me look at
him he gets to make it a name for
himself and gets to make all this money
just coming to get to fight me but so
crazy watching both of you and I
remember like people would want you to
lose but we all knew you weren't gonna
lose I don't know how they subscribe to
the idea that you're going to lose what
do you wanna do you want that okay very
brother now you know um the blunts are
good amazing listen if this is the but
go what can go wrong will go wrong it's
like what it is like the [ __ ]
it's like the witches heck if the
possibility is always a possibility
human beings are meant to fail then men
fulfills guaranteed at some point yeah
it's no [ __ ] doubt about it but what
is it gonna be damn but keep that you
thought that all your career huh
you thought that are you great no you
didn't think I don't think that but
that's the reality reality okay listen
let me tell you something you know
you'ii see guys the great fighters and
you see them sometimes punch-drunk and
stuff easy fighters even when they're
not really great fighting the [ __ ]
the concept of being a great for the the
willpower the determination the
intestinal fortitude all that stuff that
it takes to be a great fighter
skullduggery everything they all come
out like that something's wrong with
them you can't be the great without that
you can't have the spirit of the great
one like this here a guys ain't around
fighting he get brain damage but it's
not because he couldn't fight because he
had the spirit of a great fighter he
wanted it he wanted to grab that he
wanted to be bold he wanted to take that
chance
and that's what happens to us I wouldn't
be surprising the [ __ ] couple of years
I may be twitching or something maybe
having that shit's the way it is it's
just the way it is how do you feel now
Mike I don't know I feel good but I
noticed something wrong you ever felt
that about something you feel good for
something's not right sometimes yeah why
did I get upset just now that kind of
[ __ ] yeah well I think you're doing a
lot to put yourself in the best
situations possible for as long as
possible
I agree you know but listen everybody in
sports even like for everybody it's an
unwritten law when you sign that
contract and we've seen it as kids we
watched it growing up watching boxing he
theme that I've seen everybody that
watched boxing scene in their life when
you write that country I want to be a
professional boxer it's an unwritten law
that it's a possibility I might die in
training it's a possibility I may die in
a fight but stare but it's unwritten we
know that's a possibility but we give
our life up to be there on the top of
the chain of this [ __ ] game
I left me nothing built up [ __ ] you
found my life away wow that's crazy
you didn't think you're coming in for
this I didn't know what the [ __ ] I was
but I'm glad I'm glad I came and it's an
honor for sure it's great having you
know Oh anytime I want to uh flip hope
we can get your [ __ ] [ __ ] you got a
hundred and fifty nine
oh yeah no fun let's come on can we come
on you're sure love to bring my co-hosts
here we do it here let's do though yeah
awesome and Melissa I mean she's gonna
love to smoke she smokes so yeah we're
okay like go home [ __ ] blunt and [ __ ]
my wife let me smoke the faint blood of
a [ __ ] man I'll just [ __ ] around she's
gonna keep that [ __ ] [ __ ] separate in
there but equal it's all good separate
equal listen well thank you for having
me thanks brother that's really
appreciate it man thank you honey thank
you great up Mike all right let's help
that but you won't say anything let them
know where they can find you just follow
us at Hollywood unlocks all you need to
know and the only Jason oh the only
Jason Lee yeah yeah Jason Lee [ __ ]
Instagram Instagram Twitter loot all
that [ __ ] hey everybody thank you again
for watching thanks for listening head
to hotboxing podcast.com alright guys
until next time I'm up in Britain I
might think that we're out we're out in
peace peace
[Music]